substance which is believed to be
cocaine was found Sunday evening in a
routine check by the Secret Service
sparking a precautionary closure of the
White House complex altogether D.C fire
was called to investigate and quickly
determine the item to be non-hazardous
and performed preliminary field tests
which tested positive for cocaine the
president and his family were not home
at the time having left for Camp David
on Friday and came back here to the
White House yesterday according to law
enforcement officials briefed the bag of
powder was found in a work area of the
West Wing that could have been
accessible to many people including
staff or visitors even tourists
yesterday the Secret Service issued a
statement saying the item was sent for
further evaluation and they are
investigating the cause and manner of
how it entered the White House the
Secret Service will lead a full review
which will include Consulting cameras
and entrance logs to determine who had
access to the space